ああああああ
イベントレザー
排気音がよろしくお願いしまーす
ええええええ
すごく緊張しています uf
a 混ぜニャンに期待ですけども
見せ所ですねいいでしょうか聞いたので紹介見たかっていう方がいるそうです
ブーブー言っは
いい2人でいが一生懸命頑張っております
a 自己紹介文の取得した一転しておきたいですけども a まずえ私1978年
生まれの39歳
3月で40歳クラス a 誕生日プレゼントお待ちしております
a ですねそしてね
1,913件さん39歳生まれまして慎重な142センチです
低身長というねた病気なんですけどまぁアンネル病気なんですけれどもこの動きデー
軟骨の病気なんですけれども身長は楽以外がいなく pt でございますこの通り
できるございますよろしくお願いします
a 夢ですね夢
って夢はですね僕のですね小さい
身長が小さかった部分もありまして a
就職なバーですねあの仕事実もなぁ感じ数
仕事を名節にては
音さええー全然他の仕事にもつける
全然どうしようもなかったんですねこの中で綺麗じゃなかったとかいらっしゃると思う
んですけれども
経営者の中で僕みたいや市町の人がですねもし
演説言ったらえーどうかがでしょうか
まあ見たあああ
ねえな身長て新大将街に対して理解がある方がターン
アーマー値以下あんですけどもやっぱりか ic 潮流だけで何もできないだろうと
いうことでへパコしてしまうと思うんですかあでもうこっち
進歩がないじゃあああっにょ
いうふうに a
やってやりました
ビネット丸富を初めて見たときは本当に状況を受けたんですけどもこれだからできるん
じゃないかということで
あげ
税2004年ですね2010年に初めて安全日本女子プロレスという穴明団体営
も書きまし手配致しました
そしてですねそこで初めて8試合もさせていただいて皆様いる
今から補給したりとかしてテーマはしていろいろ仕事をさせていただきました
そうしたらですね archon 仕事だったらでやっていけるなと思ったんですけど
も
そしたら2005年の121
百田氏そしたら浸透をおっしゃったんですね
可能
もその時点でええやんぬゲットるってながら他の団体やん
開きたいというかやっぱり僕とフッターの話がいなかったのでそうじゃなかったんです
近いですけ
ならどっちから会わなかった時点でも絶対に伝えてくれなかった大きな人とに合わせて
もらえなくて
じゃあこうしようかなぁ考えて
これまでは僕のネットプロレスの日に消えてしまいますし
僕がお伝えしかもいないのでどっちか聞いた時点で終わりなんですね
じゃあこうしような考えた時に
悩みました本当にへ
そしてですねー
入れと取れず表現さの以内にはどうしたらいいかと思いまして
一生懸命
玄関って言ったんですけれどもなかなか際に使ってくれるもなくてうぐぅっ
なるって言ったんですけど
ねえ
夢としてはですねやっぱり僕にタイアップ委員長の人たちが
保管を去っていただくいるん頑張っているんで
夢でもあるような段差
pros の団体変化の団体があっていただけるようなえー何から地盤を作りたかった
んですねども
一番が作るにはどうしたらいいか10人がもってしかないなと思いまして
でそしてやっていったんですけれども
低日にも出たい改めまして
ででテレビ業界とかもっきって言ったんですけれどもそれはですね何年か前に最初は
切れ当局も
てる中継されてたんです全然全日本女子プロレスの中継がなかってもいつの頃から母
中間じゃなくなってしまいましたそれはなぜかというと
a gk なぁ
の方々がやっぱりそのこびと達文 l のみで変わろうという視聴者の方々の
こういうのはテレビ局に行きましてん
そんなテレビ局はやっぱりこういう行為を受けた瞬間
使うの闇をなってしまいまして
でこれではやっていけないということで出てこれ数個の実でところか
その時点汚れてしまったんです
でもまあ死ぬまで示唆
大きなグループの人たちは一生懸命やってるのにしたって僕らみたいな小さいブースが
出て a
そんな挙句やってるのに頑張っているのに
それで見て変わらずっておかしくないですかん
意匠権僕らは仕事を仕上げるんですよねえお客さんもう国はフワーッと思ってないん
ですよ
わーいと思うんですよデッドドールズテーマは今からプローズでしてパール
もう本当にバーンって楽しい見たくて
ハートロサという感じ
本当に前だという1クロスをやってきたったふうに
普通を見てなぜ考えようと思ったいるのかな
ここまあ
でそういう構え通って見て頂け
そういう公園があなたず
何ですかそういう声が語って瞬間に全部遅延当たっちゃったんでえっていう受験され
なくなっちゃったんですね
そしたら僕らの仕事も全く失ってしまいまして
テレビいって誰でもその脱衣
頂くこともできないじゃあをするか
じゃあ地道に頑張ってしかないなぁと思いました
change 頑張っているんですよ
切ってここ最近の本当にありがたいことに
a 2位もっととか出せていた高がありまして a
今な木々7巻とか209さんの舞台に立たせていただくようになりまして
ありがとうどうさせて受け0時の中でやっぱりな技とか皆さんは僕らを見てそういう彼
はちょっとかは思わないですね
あーやっぱ病院に出てほしいということで
上がっていただけと思ってるんでしょこのなかっ
year
皆さんもそうなんですけど僕を見て
こういう女使ったら面白いなふうに使ったら楽しいだろうなと思って
ひゃってくれてるんですねそうかあなた軍で皆様も管へ
2年半の舞台に攻略稼働を出させていただいて
ありがたいことって地道にその活動して蹴った
おかげで最近7テレビの方にも出させて頂くようになりましてみているところです泣
下げたいです
中継されるようになったんですねでそれでそこから a 見るとクルーにテレビ中継さ
れ肌てから何このところにテレビのファーがどんどん来まして新たにことに電子もこの
どんどん増えていったんですねそしたらですねやっぱり
最近なってですね3セットの汽船うどん幅てきたえーっ
ます
テレビ出させているだろうかね最近本当にテレビの仕事も増えましてそこでも本当は
含めエプラーだったんですけども
ブーブーいただきまして本当にあの城そこから最近キターッ
溶けてき始めてるなぁと
の中では思ってるんですね
そしてですね最近になって覚えて出させていただきましたけどね
じゃあ
朝敵僕を見てやっぱりまだ
ん嫌な人もいるらしいです正直なところ
twitter か facebook をやっているんですけれども a それを
見るとやっぱりまだまだ22 z クルーズに対して金券品という人も高いみたいで
でもええええ
尻尾を持って自分達って考えれば構えようとか言ってますけど
それパターンある記念車でしょあーあかんだと目で言ってるだけでしょうってなーんか
つの良い意味での記念車変わろう底から俺ら地獄張ってじゃあな
可愛いのでなんですかって話でしょ
た仕事を奪っているのはあなたたちつい例はれてるんですからねって話なんですよ
紀元社のかなぁと今僕は戦ってると思ってるんですね
自転車
あきりでみんなそう言って彼は場とか言ってる人らって紀元社刊て僕の中から
ん
でその中でどうやったらその人たちと戦うファイバーで大越かいないですよ僕通ったの
話がいないですけど今ファンタのさんもまぁ一生懸命やっておくれてますが何か僕の年
価値もといい巻てないので僕が
な一人で立場っていうもんです正直なとこってええ
僕あ
ええもうセンターなぁ前面に立つことによって
なーんもしてさーいまー自然車
人そしてテレビ業界戦っているようなので僕ザっていることによってほとんどん
僕を見て[ __ ]プロレス見れるところやりたい
そしてああ今ランサー人たちもちゃんとテレビに出れるんだろ智
えっ
いう目を持っていただきたいなく1少々てやっぱりどうしてもいい
締め方が多いと思うんです僕も小的なご縁3月でしたので
だから反対にはどうしたらいいかなと思いまして
って僕はがんばって前に出してとりあえず頑張って生きて選手たちのために頑張って
いこうバーン
思っていますで今前面に還付か戦っていますけれども
今
ジェットそして[ __ ]しの人たちに夢を持っていただけるように豪華衣装懸命頑張って
行きたいと思いますので
red cross として[ __ ]プロレスを今後
今10時に頑張っておりますのでもし機会がありましたらええっ
見ていただけたらと思いますしてああも c
いろんなお金見ていただける機会がありましたら是非来てください宜しくお願い致し
ます
ご静聴ありがとうございました